Es fantástico estar de vuelta.
Me encantan estas reuniones.
Y deben estar preguntándose ¿De qué se trata?
¿Pusieron la diapositiva equivocada?
No, no.
Vean este maravilloso animal y pregúntense -- ¿Quién lo diseñó?
Estamos en TED.
Aquí hablamos de Tecnología, Entretenimiento y Diseño y aquí tenemos a una vaca lechera.
Es un animal fantásticamente diseñado.
Estaba pensando ¿Cómo comenzar esta charla?
Y pensé, bueno, que tal los versos de Joyce Kilmer,
que dicen "Los poemas los hacen los tontos como yo,
pero solo Dios puede hacer un árbol."
Y podrían decir, "Bien, Dios diseñó a la vaca."
Sin embargo, Dios recibió mucha ayuda.
Éste es el ancestro de las vacas.
Este es el Órice.
Y fue diseñado por selección natural.
por el proceso de selección natural que llevó varios millones de años.
Y que después fueron domesticados hace miles de años.
Y los seres humanos se convirtieron en sus custodios,
y, aún sin saber qué hacían,
gradualmente lo rediseñaron y lo rediseñaron y lo rediseñaron.
Y después, recientemente, realmente empezaron a
hacer un tipo de ingeniería inversa en este animal
y averiguar cuáles eran sus partes y cómo funcionaban
y cómo podrían optimizarse; cómo hacerlas mejor.
Ahora bien, ¿Por qué estoy hablando de las vacas?
Porque quiero decir exactamente lo mismo de las religiones.
Las religiones son un fenómeno natural.
Son tan naturales como las vacas.
han evolucionado por miles de años.
Tiene una base biológica, tal como el Órice.
Han sido domesticadas, y los seres humanos
han venido rediseñando sus religiones durante miles de años.
Estamos en TED y quisiera hablarles acerca de diseño.
Porque lo que he venido haciendo durante los últimos cuatro años,
desde la primera vez que ustedes me conocieron; algunos me vieron antes en TED
cuando hablaba sobre religión, y en los últimos cuatro años
he trabajado sin descanso en este tema.
Podríamos decir que es acerca de la ingeniería inversa de las religiones.
Esta simple idea, según creo, provoca terror en muchas personas,
o enojo, o ansiedad de alguno tipo.
Y ese es el hechizo que quiero romper.
Y quiero decir, no, las religiones son un fenómeno natural importante.
Debemos estudiarlas con la misma intensidad
con la que estudiamos cualquier otro fenómeno natural importante
como el calentamiento global, cuya descripción escuchamos de Al Gore anoche.
Las religiones de hoy han sido diseñadas de manera brillante; brillantísima
Son instituciones sociales inmensamente poderosas
y muchas de sus características actuales pueden rastrearse hasta características primitivas
de las que podemos encontrar el sentido mediante la ingeniería inversa.
Y, tal como con la vaca, hay una mezcla de diseño evolutivo,
diseñado por selección natural, y "diseño inteligente";
bueno, más o menos inteligente; rediseñado por los seres humanos
que tratan de rediseñar sus religiones.
No hacemos presentaciones de libros en TED, pero voy a poner sólo una diapositiva
acerca de mi libro, ya que el mensaje que contiene
es lo que considero que este grupo debería escuchar.
Y sería muy interesante recibir sus comentarios al respecto.
Es la única propuesta política la que menciono en el libro,
en este momento en el que afirmo no conocer lo suficiente sobre religión
como para saber que otras políticas proponer.
Y es una que hace eco de los comentarios que han escuchado el día de hoy.
He aquí mi propuesta.
Voy a tomarme un par de minutos para explicarla;
Eduquemos a nuestros niños en todas las religiones del mundo desde la primaria,
en el instituto, en escuelas públicas y privadas, en la escolarización en casa.
Lo que propongo es que,
tal como requerimos de la lectura, escritura, aritmética, historia de América,
así deberíamos tener un curriculum de los hechos
acerca de todas las religiones del mundo;
acerca de su historia, acerca de sus creencias, acerca de sus textos,
su música, su simbolismo, sus prohibiciones, sus requerimientos.
Y que deberían presentarse los hechos, simple y llanamente
sin ninguna tendencia en particular, a todos los niños del país.
Y mientras le enseñen eso a los niños,
pueden enseñarles cualquier otra cosa que deseen.
Esto es, en mi opinión, la mayor tolerancia para la libertad religiosa
En tanto que se informe a los niños acerca de otras religiones
entonces puedes; a la edad que quieras y lo que quieras,
enseñarles el credo que quieres que aprendan.
Pero hazles saber también acerca de otras religiones.
Ahora, ¿por qué digo esto?
Porque la democracia depende de una población informada.
La aprobación informada es el pilar
de nuestro entendimiento de la democracia.
La aprobación desinformada no tiene ningún valor.
Es como lanzar una moneda, simplemente no cuenta.
La democracia depende de una aprobación informada.
Ésta es la manera en la que tratamos a las personas como adultos responsables.
Ahora bien, los niños de corta edad son un caso especial.
Voy a usar unas palabras que el Pastor Rick acaba de usar:
Los padres son los custodios de sus hijos.
No son de su propiedad.
Tus hijos no son de tu propiedad.
Tienes una responsabilidad con el mundo,
con el estado, con ellos, para cuidarlos correctamente.
Puedes enseñarles el credo que tu pienses que es el más importante,
pero yo digo que también tienes una responsabilidad de mantenerles informados
acerca de las otras religiones del mundo.
La razón por la que he tomado este tiempo es porque me fascina escuchar
algunas de las reacciones a mi propuesta.
Un comentario de un diario Católico la llamó "totalitaria"
Pero a mí me parece liberalista.
¿Es totalitario requerir que los niños lean, escriban y sepan aritmética?
No lo creo.
Lo que yo pido es que se enseñen hechos y sólo hechos.
No hablamos de valores, sólo hechos acerca de todas las religiones.
Otro comentarista la llamo "cómica"
A mí verdaderamente me molesta que
cualquier persona piense que esto es cómico.
A mi me parece una extensión posible
de los principios democráticos que ya tenemos,
y me sorprende pensar que haya alguien a quien esto le parezca ridículo.
Sé que muchas religiones están tan preocupadas por preservar la pureza
de su fe entre sus niños, que buscan
mantener a sus hijos en la ignorancia acerca de otras religiones.
No creo que haya ninguna excusa para esto, pero me gustaría mucho
escuchar sus comentarios y reacciones más tarde.
De momento vamos avanzando.
De regreso a la vaca.
En esta foto, que bajé de internet,
la persona de la izquierda es una parte importante de la foto.
Esta persona es el custodio.
Las vacas no podrían vivir sin sus custodios humanos; han sido domesticadas.
Son algo así como ecto-simbiontes.
Dependen de nosotros para sus supervivencia.
Y el Pastor Rick hablaba hace un momento de las ovejas.
Yo también voy a hablar de las ovejas.
Hay una maravillosa convergencia aquí.
¡Qué listas fueron las ovejas al buscarse pastores!
Piensen en todo aquello que esto les trajo.
Fueron capaces de pasarle todos sus problemas a otro,
protegerlos de los depredadores, encontrarles comida, preocuparse de su salud.
El único costo en la mayoría de las manadas es que dejarán de cruzarse libremente.
¡Un chollo!
Podrán pensar: ¡Que ovejas tan listas!
Excepto claro, porque esto no tiene que ven con lo listas que son las ovejas.
Todos sabemos que las ovejas no son lo que llamaríamos superinteligentes.
Nada tuvo que ver la inteligencia de las ovejas.
Ellos no tenían ni idea.
Pero fue una maniobra muy inteligente.
¿De quién fue esta maniobra inteligente?
Fue una maniobra inteligente de la misma selección natural.
Francis Crick, el co-descubridor de la estructura del DNA
junto con Jim Watson, comentaba en broma sobre lo que llamaba la Segunda Regla de Orgel.
Leslie Orgel es un biólogo molecular, una persona brillante,
y la Segunda Regla de Orgel es: "La Evolución es más lista que tú".
Claro que esto no es Diseño Inteligente, no de Francis Crick.
¡La Evolución es más lista que tú!
Si entienden la segunda regla de Orgel, entonces pueden ver
porque el movimiento de "Diseño inteligente" es básicamente un engaño.
Los diseños descubiertos mediante el proceso de selección natural
son brillantes, increíblemente brillantes.
Una y otra vez los biólogos se quedan maravillados con grandioso de lo que es descubierto.
Pero el proceso en sí no tiene ningún propósito,
sin previsión, sin diseño.
Cuando estuve aquí hace cuatro años,
Les conté la historia de una hormiga que escala una hoja de pasto.
¿Y cuál es la razón de la conducta de la hormiga?
Pues es porque un parásito llamado Dicrocoelium dendriticum ha infectado su cerebro.
y necesita llegar al intestino de una oveja o vaca para reproducirse.
Es como una historia de fantasmas.
Y pienso que algunas personas pudieron haberla malinterpretado.
El Dicroelium no es inteligente.
Yo diría que su inteligencia está más o menos
entre la petunia y la zanahoria.
No son muy listos y no necesitan serlo.
La lección que podemos obtener de todo esto es
que no necesitas tener un cerebro para recibir los beneficios.
El diseño esta allí en la naturaleza, pero no está en la cabeza de nadie.
No necesita estarlo.
Esa es la manera en la que la funciona la evolución.
La pregunta es: ¿Fue bueno para las ovejas ser domesticadas?
Fue fantástico para su salud genética.
Y aquí quiero recordarles un argumento maravilloso
que hizo Paul MacCready hace tres años en TED.
Esto es lo que el comentó:
Hace 10,000 años, en el amanecer de la agricultura,
la población humana junto con el ganado y las mascotas era de aproximadamente
un 0.1% de toda la masa de los vertebrados terrestres.
Eso sucedió hace 10,000 años.
En términos biológicos es como si hubiera sido ayer.
¿Cuál es la situación actual? ¿Alguien recuerda lo que Paul dijo?
Somos el 98%.
Esto es lo que hemos hecho en este planeta.
Yo estuve charlando con Paul después de su charla.
Quería verificar cómo realizó su cálculo,
y obtener las fuentes de información y otros datos.
Y me entregó un artículo que escribió acerca de esto.
Hay un párrafo que no mostró aquí
y considero que es tan bueno que voy a leerlo para ustedes.
"Durante miles de millones de años en una singular esfera,
el azar ha pintado una delgada película de vida:
compleja, improbable, maravillosa y frágil.
De repente, nosotros los humanos, una especie de reciente llegada a este mundo
dejamos de estar sujetos a las restricciones y equilibrios de la naturaleza,
hemos crecido en población, tecnología e inteligencia hasta una posición de gran poder.
Ahora somos nosotros los que blandimos el pincel".
Hemos oído hablar de la atmósfera como una delgada capa de barniz.
La vida en sí misma es sólo una capa de pintura en este planeta.
Y somos nosotros los que sostenemos el pincel.
¿Y cómo es que lo hacemos?
La clave para nuestra dominación del planeta es la cultura,
y la clave de la cultura es la religión.
Supongan que científicos marcianos vinieran a la Tierra.
Estarían intrigados por varias cosas.
¿Alguien sabe qué es esto?
Les diré que es.
Es un millón de personas reunidas en las orillas del Ganges en el 2001,
tal vez la mayor reunión de seres humanos de la historia,
vista por fotografía satélite.
Esta otra es un gran tumulto.
Y otro más en La Meca.
Los marcianos estarían maravillados por esto.
Querrían saber cómo es que se originó, qué es y cómo es que se perpetua a sí mismo.
Bueno, me voy a saltar esta parte.
Esta hormiga no esta sola.
Hay una gran variedad de casos similares.
En este caso, un parásito se introduce en un ratón
que necesita terminar en la barriga de un gato.
Y eso convierte al ratón en Super Ratón. Lo hace intrépido
de manera que se expone en lugares donde puede ser comido por un gato.
Historias verdaderas.
En otras palabras, tenemos estos secuestradores,
–ustedes vieron esta diapositiva, hace cuatro años–,
un parásito infecta el cerebro
y provoca incluso conductas suicidas en pro de una causa
diferente de la propia salud genética.
¿Sucede esto entre los humanos?
Claro que sí, y maravillosamente.
La palabra árabe "Islam" significa sometimiento
Significa rendir el propio interés a la voluntad de Alá.
Pero no sólo estoy hablando del Islam.
Estoy hablando también del Cristianismo.
Este es un pergamino con música que encontré en una librería de París hace 50 años.
Y dice así, en Latín:
(Latín)
"La palabra de Dios es la semilla y el Sembrador es Cristo."
¡La misma idea!, bueno, no exactamente.
Pero de hecho los Cristianos también están orgullosos de haber rendido su voluntad a Dios.
Les voy a leer algunas citas.
"El centro de la adoración es el sometimiento.
Las personas obedecen las palabra de Dios, aún cuando parezcan irrazonables."
Estas son palabras de Rick Warren
Vienen del libro "Una Vida con Propósito".
Y quisiera dedicar un breve tiempo a hablar acerca de este libro, que ya he leído.
Todos ustedes recibieron una copia.
Ustedes acaban de escuchar al autor.
Y quiero mencionar algunas cosas acerca de este libro desde la perspectiva del diseño,
porque considero que es un libro brillante.
Primero que nada, el objetivo.
Y ustedes escucharon cuál es el objetivo del libro.
Es dar dirección a la vida de millones de personas... y ha tenido éxito.
¿Es un noble objetivo?
En si mismo, podemos estar de acuerdo, es un objetivo maravilloso.
Da exactamente en el clavo.
Hay mucha gente en el mundo que no encuentra dirección en sus vidas,
y darle propósito a todas esas vidas en un objetivo maravilloso.
Yo le doy un 10 en esto.
¿Se cumple el objetivo?
Si.
Se han vendido 30 millones de copias de este libro.
Al Gore, para que aprendas.
(Risas)
Rick está haciendo lo mismo que Al Gore está tratando de hacer.
Este es un logro increíble.
Y los medios. ¿Cómo es que lo logra?
Empleando un brillante rediseño de temas religiosos,
actualizándolos, quitándole algunas características obsoletas,
dando nuevas interpretaciones a otras características.
Esta es la evolución de las religiones que ha estado llevándose a cabo durante miles de años,
y este es el mas reciente ejemplo de esta práctica.
No tengo que decirles esto.
Ustedes acaban de escuchar al autor.
Ideas excelentes acerca de la psicología humana, recomendaciones prudentes en cada página.
Es más, nos invita a mirar más allá de la superficie.
Y agradezco eso.
Por ejemplo, tiene un apéndice donde explica
su elección de traducciones de diferentes versículos de la Biblia.
El libro es claro, intenso, accesible, con un bello formato.
Suficiente repetición.
Esto es muy importante.
Cada vez que lo lees o lo dices, haces otra copia en el cerebro.
(Risas)
Todos conmigo, vamos: Cada vez que lo lees o lo dices,
haces otra copia que en el cerebro.
Gracias.
Y ahora vamos a otro problema.
Porque soy absolutamente sincero en mis comentarios
acerca de este libro.
Pero me gustaría que fuera mejor.
Tengo algunos problemas con este libro.
Y sería un hipócrita si no los mencionara.
Me gustaría que el autor hiciera una revisión,
algo como la versión 2.0
"La verdad los hará libres"...
eso es lo que dice en la Biblia y a mi también me gustaría vivir de ese modo.
Mi problema es que no creo que muchas de esas partes sean verdaderas.
En algunos casos es una diferencia de opinión,
y esa no es mi queja principal.
Pero vale la pena mencionarlo.
Aquí tenemos un pasaje – más o menos lo mismo que él dijo:
"Si no hubiera Dios, todos seríamos accidentes,
seríamos el resultado de azares astronómicos del Universo.
Podrías dejar de leer este libro porque la vida
no tendría entonces significado, dirección ni propósito.
No habría bien ni mal ni esperanza más allá de tu breve estancia en la Tierra."
Pues simplemente no lo creo.
Por cierto, la película de Homer Groening
presenta una alternativa hermosa para este mismo comentario.
Hay significado y razón para el bien y el mal.
No necesitamos creer en Dios para ser buenos o tener significado en nuestras vidas.
Pero esa es sólo una diferencia de opinión.
Y no es lo que más me preocupa.
¿Que tal esto? "Dios diseñó el medio ambiente de este planeta para que nosotros pudiéramos vivir en él."
Me temo que mucha gente puede usar ese sentimiento para hacernos creer
que no tenemos que hacer las cosas que Al Gore
trata desesperadamente que hagamos.
Y no me siento bien con ese sentimiento.
Y después encontramos esto: "Toda la evidencia disponible en las ciencias biológicas...
apoya la idea de que el cosmos ha sido especialmente diseñado para
contener seres vivos y a los seres humanos como su propósito fundamental,
un todo en el que todas las facetas de la realidad derivan su significado
de este hecho central"
Esto es de Michael Denton. Un creacionista.
Y aquí pienso, "Espera un segundo."
Lo vuelvo a leer.
Y lo leo tres o cuatro veces más y pienso,
"¿Este hombre está promoviendo el diseño inteligente?
¿Está apoyando al creacionismo aquí?"
Pero no se puede discernir.
Así que entonces pienso, "Bien, no lo se,
no se si quiero enfurecerme con esto todavía."
Pero entonces sigo leyendo y me encuentro con: "Primero, Noé nunca había visto llover,
porque antes del diluvio Dios regaba la tierra de abajo hacia arriba."
Me gustaría que ese párrafo no estuviera allí porque es totalmente falso.
Y considero que pensar de esa manera acerca de la historia de nuestro planeta,
después de lo que hemos escuchado acerca de la historia
del planeta a lo largo de millones de años,
aleja a la gente del entendimiento científico.
Ahora que Rick Warren usa términos científicos, medio-científicos
e información de una manera muy interesante.
Aquí esta una: "Dios deliberadamente te moldeó y formó para que lo sirvieras
de una manera que hace tu ministerio único.
Cuidadosamente mezcló el coctel de DNA que te creó."
Yo creo que esto es falso.
Ahora, tal vez quisiéramos tratar esto como metafórico.
Aquí está otra: "Por ejemplo, tu cerebro puede almacenar 100 billones de hechos.
Tu mente puede manejar 15,000 decisiones cada segundo."
Sería interesante encontrar la interpretación de este párrafo que pudiera aceptar.
Debería haber alguna forma de tratarla como verdadera.
"Los antropólogos se han dado cuenta de que hay una necesidad universal de adoración,
programada por Dios en cada fibra de nuestro ser,
una necesidad innata de conectarnos con Dios."
Pues bien, hasta cierto punto podría estar de acuerdo con él,
excepto que creo que hay una explicación evolutiva detrás de esto.
Y lo que verdaderamente me inquieta acerca de este libro
es que argumenta que si deseas ser moral.
si quieres dar significado a tu vida,
tienes que ser partidario del Diseño Inteligente; tienes que negar
la Teoría de la Evolución por Selección Natural.
Y considero que, por el contrario, para resolver los problemas
de nuestro mundo es necesario que no tomemos en serio la biología evolutiva.
¿Cuál es la verdad que vamos a escuchar?
Tal vez esta de "Una Vida con Propósito":
"La Biblia debe convertirse en la autoridad de mi vida,
la brújula en la que confío y el consejo que escucho
para tomar decisiones sabias y como referencia para evaluar cualquier cosa."
¿Y qué se derivará entonces de aquí?
Y aquí hay algo que me inquieta sobremanera.
Recuerden que hace unos momentos cité esta misma línea:
"Las personas obedecen las palabra de Dios, aun cuando parezcan irrazonables"
Y ahí está el problema.
"No trates de razonar con el Demonio.
Es mucho mejor que tú en eso, ya que tiene miles de años de experiencia."
Ahora que Rick Warren no inventó esta brillante estrategia.
Es una estrategia muy vieja.
Es una brillante adaptación de las religiones.
Es un comodín para alejarse de cualquier crítica razonable.
"¿No te gusta mi interpretación?
¿Tienes alguna objeción razonable al respecto?
¡No escuches, no escuches!
Es el lenguaje del Demonio."
Y esto nos aleja de cualquier acercamiento juicioso
que en mi opinión deberíamos tener.
Tengo un último problema
y verdaderamente me gustaría una respuesta de Rick si es capaz de darla.
"En una gran reunión, Jesús dijo, 'Vayan con la gente de todas las naciones
y háganlos mis discípulos, bautícenlos en el nombre del Padre,
del Hijo y del Espíritu Santo, enséñenles a ellos todo cuanto les he dicho."
La Biblia dice que Jesús es el único que puede salvar al mundo.
Hemos visto maravillosos mapas del mundo
durante estos días.
Aquí tenemos uno, no tan bonito como los anteriores.
Muestra simplemente las religiones del mundo.
Y aquí esta otro que muestra la difusión actual aproximada de las diferentes religiones.
De verdad queremos comprometernos a absorber
todas las otras religiones cuando sus libros sagrados les dicen,
"¡No escuches a la otra parte, es Satanás hablando!"
Me parece que esa es una apuesta problemática
para enfrentar el futuro.
Me encontré con este anuncio cuando viajaba hacia Maine hace poco,
delante de una iglesia: "La bondad sin Dios se convierte en nada."
Simpático.
Un pequeño y brillante meme.
Simplemente no lo creo, y creo que esta idea, a pesar de su popularidad,
es en si misma uno de los principales problemas a los que nos enfrentamos.
Si ustedes son como yo, conocen a muchos maravillosos y comprometidos
ateos y agnósticos que son buenos sin ningún Dios.
Y también conocen a muchas personas religiosas que se esconden tras su santurronería
en lugar de hacer el bien.
Así que quisiera que nos deshiciéramos de este meme.
Me gustaría que este meme se extinguiera.
Muchas gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)